par les enfants bonsoir bonsoir mais oui
ce soir je vais raconter une histoire à
nicolas la pape rhône elle une histoire
qu'ils aiment beaucoup
dibi dibi dit on les châles l'ofppt bbt
du midi dépit du
bon sens
ces cas là raconte une histoire oui une
histoire de la petite philippine et de
son lapin blanc d'accord
un instant je me pose
là écoutez bien en descendant de l'avion
le papa la maman
philippines qui jouait du tambour
et le lapin blanc
découvrir la mer
ce qui l'est déjà la chance leurs
chaussures et leurs valises à la main
ils l'on gère la plage jusqu'à leur
hôtel
quant à leurs chances et marcher dans le
sable roma l'a
plutôt union l'air malin comme ça
bonjour monsieur
nous avons réservé une grande chance
pour
un monsieur d'une gamme et une petite
fille oui ce saut mais pas par un lapin
blanc monsieur et notre hôtel ne loge
pas tenable en raison
d'ennuis leurs chaussures et leurs
valises à la main ils marchèrent jusqu'à
l'hôtel suivant non monsieur notre
établissement les berges pas les lapins
blanche
après être allé dans plusieurs autres
hôtels où l'on acceptait pas non plus
les lapins blancs et fatiguée de porter
leurs bagages
il décida
au nom nicolas et s'ils n'aiment pas le
tél
exactement et une fille du grand pin
c'est bien plus amusant ce soir là le
papa et la maman de philippines sont
dormino pas très content
tandis que leur petite fille
ravie
regardais les étoiles
etc ou tel bruit de la main en compagnie
de son ami à ses parts à
ti vd des bd bd tu étudies pbd qui
fêtait
elles jouaient du tambourin nous mais si
mal elle jouait de thabo si vous voulez
un jouet du tambour
et voilà les enfants histoire terminée
vous l'avez mais oui beaucoup et bien je
vous donne le lien si maintenant
[Musique]
collection la prison nous allons l'y
leur petit pas de maillé runners bonne
nuit les enfants
fait pour
[Musique]
typique du début du début des mapa roll
mais c'est le lapin blanc mais n'ont pas
trop ce mois nounours
je vous ai bien notre paix allant en
route gros farceur bonne eu des enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents faites
votre toilette n'oubliez pas de vous
l'avez lu ton est faite de pur
[Musique]
oh
on